okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is the what could be
called the missing meeting but that will
be very confusing it's a we're going to
be talking about a handling and missing
data this is all stuff for post version
12 okay so let's go through some of this
stuff so so one of the issues I mean
there are there's missing data there's
exceptions those are slightly different
kinds of things
okay so we're talking about I mean we
have things like delete missing right
now what is missing behavior where does
that show up oh boy that's part of the
the data sets story is that correct
yes I'm free a missing data rules whoo
that's again something very different
missing style okay so that's something
that probably should be generalized to
many things is that not correct what do
you mean which direction
well I mean the missing style is
something like how do you display
something whose value is missing I mean
because in this case with
regionalization functions where you have
an object for the thing you just don't
know what color it should be right
what's another example I mean geo geo
region value plot I mean it should be
supported within or a plot but isn't yet
icing so in a ray plot I mean if I say
continents here and then I say um let's
say what would I say I would say
population what happens if I just say
how do I make am a thing suitable for um
I know what happens if I do that does
that produce a list or does that yes oh
I know missing I thought I'd talk to who
knows okay there's 4,500 people down
there apparently so lots of all people
okay Anthony Association is that way
you're mmhmm yeah looking for yeah so
come to me donation in that input comer
Association I'm not into the Association
okay Tony
Oh velvet spelled wrong you're not
spilling Association right missing an
eye yeah but but that okay but but so
that should be okay can you report that
to user assistance for that say that's a
bug in the UM an auto could be well
maybe it's a bug not a complete okay
well let me let me really cheat here and
let me just edit this
let's let's make Australia be missing
okay say we don't have anybody in
Australia on the phone call doing yeah
it's like 3:00 a.m. so I think I think
we're okay okay so this is going to be
why this is taking so long but um so
this should be coloring this according
to those values why is it taking so long
it's and those indigo sophistic contents
which are watch okay right so Australia
is gray we know that it's in the set but
we don't know what its population is so
if I say missing style arrow white here
then Australia will be white okay so the
analogous cases to this are um things
like putting missing in an array plot
what are some other examples of that bar
chart I mean bar chart has a very old
behavior that predates missing which
ignores non-numerical things no no no
bar chart is not the case for this
because bar charts can't do anything
with missing
I mean well bar chart does the right
thing I'm pretty sure you know if you do
bar chart of 1 comma missing comma 2
yeah it doesn't sort the same thing for
1 comma X cot oh it's that's why I'm
saying it predates missing right I mean
with this functions there are other
things than missing in the world that's
not real right but in the case of bar
chart we leave a space for the bar
exactly we don't have any height to
render it at that's what's missing right
whereas all the database functions that
haven't written in some funky way you
know in other words from the biz team
they do handle anomalous data and it's
not missing specifically missing is just
one out of many
you know unev al you ate that
indeterminate complex values to all
kinds of things that are anonymous
anomalous ok so
well let's talk about that for a second
I mean so you say something like this
okay so is there there is no missing
style for that Latrese yeah I mean you
would have to render along the axis or
something right because we don't have
that there's no bar height to fill in
well I could it could it could render a
frowny face here or something somebody
could render graphics above the the axis
that are just an indicator that it is
missing no it could run me an arrow
could I mean as I said we at the time
when all these designs were done you
know should it should it do that for you
know indeterminates
once I sue sue Leonato weird things that
the system can produce right
what would you didn't call it basic
value yeah I understand there's a good
example from the live stream which is
weather data where some data points are
missing um and in that case with
dateless plot the default behavior but I
don't think we have we don't have a
missing value mechanism in dateless plot
do we know I mean it just leaves gaps
you know so that is the mechanism you
know and that took some effort actually
so you can have that even when it's not
data so our functions sometimes don't
produce real values believe it or not
they produce complex values they produce
indeterminate stay produce infinities
they produce all kinds of funky things
and and we did some in that case we know
the data up to that point so they needed
to do special things to home in and and
refine around that so if you plot the
comp you know square root of I don't
know 1 minus x squared plus y squared
about 3d of that and you can see how it
refines around that square root of that
so it's just something bad
square root and 1 minus X square plus
and a minus y squared and and then just
plot that from minus 1 to 1 for both of
them
that will look very ugly before we added
several layers that does that kind of
refinement nice refinement on the edge
to make it a proper right and it's
beautiful on trivial okay but in that
case again you've got missing stuff
around rain but generally what we do is
to you know for all these misfortunes we
show nothing because there is nothing
it's missing right but yeah but the
problem is Australia isn't missing in
this case right which is why it has a
missing style right the value of
Australia's missing that we still have a
representation of right we have a
special representation of the label that
we don't necessarily have right in in
other another case of this is presumably
a plot where right there's some generic
it's red yeah it's that color which is
not terrible but I mean that that
presumably should have a missing style
correct yeah right but that's another
where like Australia it's it's got space
allocated for it right if we were to
leave it blank it would look white and
you would interpret it differently right
because white actually has meaning in
all right in that grayscale color
function yeah i as an aside if we ever
do musical notation things there is a
style that's used when the pitch is not
precise which is an X instead of a
circle or an X we're in the in the stage
like where where the circular part of
the note would normally be you have an
okay so for example for drums it you're
gonna have different heights of X
because it's just I'm precise [ __ ] it
doesn't mean that it doesn't have [ __ ]
so it's around the C
it's sex all right there um that's
interesting okay let's go to other types
of missingness you so I mean one is in
graphics another is in for example you
know if I say um and then I say mean of
that list it will just do the wrong
thing right well it depends on your
definition of wrong I don't know I mean
let's say we have a team let's call them
V a instead of W a let's say that they
throw in a new symbol they call it I
don't know imaginary or something and
none no system no look look okay really
useful to be able to deal with this in
some reasonable way right which is which
is mean of delete missing of your list
right I assume me assuming that that's
the correct way of handling missing
right now the other another alternative
is to say oh no there's a data point
missing that means we just don't know
what the mean is and so and so I really
don't have a problem with the symbolic
results because after all this is a
symbolic language I say I think it's
highly I think it's highly misleading if
we if we were to automatically delete
nothing well okay let me retract that I
got kind of side with Stephen I think we
should actually like that I think what
we need to do when we introduce objects
is to think a little bit the head
instead of throwing them in and then
hope for the best
Roger if we could see a head if at all
moments we could see infinitely a head
we would be in much better shape and we
probably also do nothing well there is
that it's really hard to foresee
everything so let's not beat ourselves
up about that what's the point here I
mean III do take your point that um you
know different behaviors for missing
which include you know one is you know
just to drop that point
and to is if there's something missing
we can't we don't know the answer
there's probably something in between
say what we do in food data if you have
12,000 cookies then you won't mean
address or missing who cares but if it's
opposite it metals there's a hurricane
missing which is called sensor data
which is a type of missing data a more
specific form yeah and when we
introduced that we did think about sort
of the processing pipeline for it and
also there's a whole you know it's
called survival analysis you know
there's a whole set of things to deal
with that yeah and and I think that the
most problematic thing about that anti
value example is that the ratio between
the adiabatic index and the atomic
radius is one because I think that it's
very weird that missing simplify if you
take the adiabatic index and do atomic
radius they're both missing and no
they're not both I mean let's take a
case where they're the same type of
missing they will cancel out in a Nancy
function that's a weird I agree that
would be totally totally weird I mean if
we do this for let's say right or if you
divide by the adiabatic index by the
atomic radius not sure why you'd want to
do that but if you did you'd end up with
what is that what you're saying Carlo
yeah that's a horrifying and scary yeah
right so that's the question of adding
more information to and to missing so
the more information it has the more
useful it's alright
and making an essentially UUID missings
not necessarily I mean to me the most
important thing is to know what it came
from so the information of which
function generated it no but so you you
ID'd them because otherwise you end up
with missing divided by missing as
right Wow they don't have to be you you
daddy like you you leave it it's is the
same value but they would have to read
you your IDs yeah is not I mean the
police should not should never be equal
to itself so well look this is this is
really what this would be okay so one
version of this would be but it's then a
bit circular and complicated I mean okay
so this will be one version hold of
einsteinium okay so while you're typing
that and so Carlos so you're saying that
if I did
einsteinium of density equals a stadium
of density I should get false well it
depends on the missing the point my
point is that so when we're talking
about SQL there are effectively two
types of missing one is the missing that
says I don't know what this column is
and another is in this particular data
point I have no data the second type
which is the null in SQL is a lot like
another number in in IE whatever number
that is I Triple E yeah I believe 17
whatever so so you're saying that the
the types of missing so we can
characterize types of missing right this
particular value is missing but the
structure is okay yeah that was what we
called the data missing and the other
one was a schema missing oh that's
various qle right okay um there's
structurally nothing there right so is
that roughly missing of not available
versus missing of not applicable
Rober is it a piece of the real world I
mean you know
not of not applicable would be something
like the the melting point of helium for
example does anybody used those reasons
for missing have never seen any code
that uses them for anything we put a lot
of effort in alpha to return that I'd
missing but but why I mean what so that
we can get out for the test state of
somebody who's still alive it's very
important that you tell you the reason
it's missing is not because we didn't
find it but because he's still alive but
does anybody use that you know well
visual display we use it for alpha all
the time don't we certainly use it the
right the user uses it when they look at
it right they may not use it
computationally but but Michael is
saying that alpha uses it
computationally as well before what we
put in a pot like we don't say we don't
know vegetables inside we said he's
still alive right right but I still
think that not applicable not available
are both data missing and so they should
not be equal to applicable means that in
principle you should have had a
different entity type so that entity
type is fully characterized by their
violet poverty's if it's not applicable
then it's a different thing yeah yeah I
agree but what I'm saying is that we see
not applicable just like missing not
available works like not a number you
just should not be component to anything
there's another side too there's sort of
scaler missings but if you have big data
and you have a lot of missings they're
very big they're very the
of representation issues same thing that
happened with quantities you know if you
have ten thousand quantities it was so
big you couldn't fine you're just
objecting to details of the
implementation Roger I mean we're trying
to understand look we're trying to
understand what design we want to get
here then we will loop back to try to
understand how we implement it I mean I
think that roger has a very important
point here it's that we should work on
supporting missing on numeric array for
communication without languages for
example in talk about supporting not a
number I certainly disagree that we
should support missing in there right
and then and and not a number is on to
the on the to-do list they don't I can't
promise it on any particular day what
what is not what is it in our language
if you importance I terminate not a
number I see so so this imports as
indeterminate which is its own poisoned
version of missing right it poisons
arithmetic but not other operations so
right you can say one plus in
determinant equals two and that will
give indeterminate equals two right even
if I say
indeterminate / indeterminate I will get
indeterminate right but if you do
indeterminant equals something it'll
just stay under valuated okay right
which is different from undefined for
example which is you know just which is
completely undefined and all therefore
also poison
what is undefined and what does that
show up so for examples that have
undefined values so for instance a
conditional expression will have to
return that I have forgotten we ever
have this so if I say undefined so this
is also known as bots in computer
science right the bottom element in the
semantics of programming languages this
is this is equivalent to bought
undefined yeah the factor in determinate
equals equals 3 does not evaluate means
that we are not compliant wind ie we're
not committing to the fact that
indeterminate is exactly the same as the
random thing in this stupid standard
which I don't it yeah it's a horrifying
standard anyway but that's different
issue yes all right sure how many people
here can quote it and argue
intelligently about it so okay okay so
let's let's continue scoping out what
we're talking about here okay so let's
just look at this let's just go through
this agenda and then I want to come back
and talk about the different
complications of this okay I don't know
Stan what this is they use the second
argument of missing this is talking
about the fact that missing is also used
to report invalid names which is a bit
of a stronger error well that's again
that's that's almost like your schema
error here right I mean so this one here
is there structurally nothing there
that's that case as opposed to there is
um you know as opposed to this case
where that is there's nothing wrong with
the structure the structure is okay you
can define you can meaningfully in
principle define you know an adiabatic
index for uranium that's just surprised
that that's not known because well it
depends on whether it's a monatomic gas
or not um those three were examples of
three things that syntactically are
correct but they returned three
different reasons so one is right you'd
also get something like right if you did
Association it goes to B of C right okay
so let's let's look at that so if we say
hey ro B okay so which one is that
that is more the structural one correct
that's more this one isn't it that would
be my instinct but I guess Carlos the
sequel expert in your relation I think
it's just an independent use of missing
well but this is data dependent and this
is structure Carla can you speak to that
sorry can you repeat the question
no the the Association behavior a goes
to B F C gives missing of key absent
that's us that's at schema me see okay
so the next I don't know what this
comparison null value is okay fine
aggregation values have an implicit
delete missings
okay okay well that's you know that's a
question of you know um arithmetic /
statistics / statistics / machine
learning
with missings right so in the case of
arithmetic you know that's the case of
mean and as Michael points out what this
does can somewhat depend on how many
missings there are because I mean for
example if I say mean of missing missing
it's kind of horrifyingly just give me a
single missing isn't it right but it
might be it so what should this do if
you've got 300 values and one missing
poisoning the whole thing is probably
not what you want well I don't know I
mean on the other hand if we said max of
two three missing who knows what that
should be see what I'm saying and
actually that behavior right now is
pretty good for max right I mean they
think more I think I mean ice on a
certain level right I think you have a
better argument with you know median I
mean I mean I think it's problematic to
just automatically throwing missings but
you have a better argument with median
right because if you have 301 median
you're at most off by one right
if you don't know yeah but if it's 300
missings and one value you don't panic
is that one value I see what you're
saying that the main point you're making
is that's sort of what it means to be
robust statistics we have somebody from
the statistics team that that's a
perfectly reasonable error message right
it's telling you that missing is not a
number so it can't compute the median
but wait a minute am I am I being
confused or is it the case that if I
have enough numbers here the fact that
there's one missing one doesn't matter
of course it matters
yeah you don't know you don't know how
to you don't know where to sort in the
missing I see right I mean
you can give a good if you have 300 you
can probably give a pretty good
approximation right if we had a median
around so for example if we have I mean
in this case right this case I bet we're
not gonna do it but we could do if we
did a mean around here
that could give a meaningful value is
that true no now because you have no
idea what that number could be 10
gazillion yes exactly
we don't need median around could give a
reasonable results right okay Ethan on
our live stream is is expressing the
desire for good ways of interoperating
with Python and numpy and commenting
that missings will interfere with
generating json and numeric arrays well
that's another interesting question is
import and export exported missings what
should we do I'm sorry that what
interferes with what generating json
generating json okay what does json do
what should what would it what would be
a reasonable thing to convert the
missing to for json anybody have an idea
there and what would be an appropriate
thing to do I don't know I don't know
what it does
presumably it gives some sort of expert
like thing or is that because it's sort
of defaulting to Rogerson and you need
to say like expression Jason no it's it
oh maybe but but do we actually have I
mean I mean that the real issue right is
and there is no good JSON for an
arbitrary expression well I know that
but there may be some special
representation for misses now there
isn't they've now in Jason and John
Street they also have undefined but I
think they just might so one thing that
comes out of this is we might want an
option for JSON export that says what to
do with missings and that might not want
to be restricted to I mean assuming that
Jason doesn't have nan or maybe it does
I'm not an expert in JSON but right
maybe we need a general not you know and
general other function not just missing
possibly you know even if Jason does
have man which I don't think it does
so guarantee that you're missing is a
numeric thing well no I ain't but I
meant for right but what if you have in
indeterminates in there those are
definitely Nan's right yeah I was about
to ask what happens if you try to export
an indeterminate to Jason well anyway
then python has none which is not like
our none it's like the null in
JavaScript okay all right so look that's
gonna see what to do with these but I
mean that this is this is probably not a
I mean we've got you know we've had
let's see no we had a missing style but
this is this is as you say not missing
this is this is some I know what this
should be called and we've had this in
some other export formats where we have
to give some default behavior
okay let's take a look that's often what
happens on import okay so let's say
Excel doesn't have a particular way of
handling missing which it doesn't and so
what people do is that they encode some
special value to be the missing and
that's usually you know in the notes in
and around the data set yeah I
understand and that's that's that kind
of convention is used for an awful lot
of data formats actually yeah but so
what are you suggesting but right when
one differently though is that you can
put anything into an excel so and so and
so our default for exporting an
arbitrary wolfram language expression to
excel is to just stringify it yes and
then you just see the the full form or
whatever it is inside inside the excel
cell but I'll let you know Jason okay
okay you probably want to convert it to
something you know in either direction
on import or export you
the question is should we make it
service functions should have options
that make you you know the place yes
right there right okay so let's take a
look at a few of the other issues that
are highlighted in here and then I want
to come back propagation of missing yeah
I mean this is a horrible mess what to
do with all of this horrible mess I mean
as you say we've got indeterminate
undefined which I had forgotten and
we've got missing and yeah I mean both
indeterminate undefined don't need to
have privatization because they are
simply poisonous and they don't you know
this you you I doing business is
irrelevant to them okay list ability I'm
missing what's this about this the idea
that it's not good to return a single
missing when do you want to mean a list
of mostly missing
is there a case where we do that well it
has been suggested sometimes for example
that if it is a full list of missing we
could return a single missing and I
think that's an error because most
functions will be prepared to get a list
you know I don't think it's right thing
I don't think we should modify the
structure unless we absolutely have to
correct okay so just details okay so
yeah sorry about that
so the idea my suggestion would be to
add as much information as we can in the
missing objects okay if we feel that we
have to make missing a blob not because
we don't want to display I which I think
wouldn't be a bad thing anyway
because if we then have a more powerful
delete missing for example able to look
at patterns and things like that
we would have very powerful tools to
decide a posteriori what we want to do
fine I think that's good and I think but
I think just having it format as a blob
so we don't have all of
the random details hanging out here
would be a good thing anybody object to
that no okay so I think we should we
should do that um I mean I mean by blob
do you mean a summary boxer do you mean
some new type of formatting right there
not sure I'm not sure what we're I think
it shouldn't be too heavy I don't think
it should be a full summary box okay
yeah I think it'd be nice to just have a
thing that says I I don't know what the
right format is but I wouldn't give all
the details in here I mean you just
don't care about those good did you know
what the traditional form of missing is
no I don't what is it it'd be prepared
very minimal - its and - yes tip yeah
okay
so you know it's not crazy crazy but I
don't think we want that in standard
form but I wouldn't I mean I think we
want to display it explicitly but we
wouldn't want its tentacles coming in
mm-hmm so there's just a gray
roundedrect around of nicely something
yeah something like that yes I think
that's right I mean it particularly if
the reasons are you know key absent not
available and so and it's clear that
those are things that aren't there in
some way okay so a question for the
board from Alpha developers is there any
reason why currently missing doesn't add
more information why in many cases it's
just an empty or just as interesting
it's probably mostly for Jeremy because
kind of filling the various there's a
little bit of a pain in the databases it
also be general data not combining
things so if you have more than one you
die I think there's a bunch of things so
for example a packet developer gets
dispersed
by you know should the default missing
be not available or not applicable or
something else but that you know already
precludes the second argument right
because what you're really doing is
you're saying hey it's not there in the
database and then it gets filled in
beyond that you know yeah I you might be
asking you know why don't we have this
second argument that was the original
expression in there I assume that was
the question yes and I could I could
believe that that's just historical sir
certainly certainly the design of how
pack let's return missing well predates
me okay so that should be investigated
um okay here's a question about
visualization of missing do we what do
we want to give messages when do we want
to give messages I think we do want some
kind of messaging right because
otherwise you're like oh my gosh there
were no battles in the in the South
Pacific or something but oh well
actually that's just because the data
was wrong am I making sense yes that's
the reason why do a fix before
eliminating because otherwise the map
would pink it reports them isn't it well
why would it be okay but but pinking is
just wrong I mean this you know yeah so
it's following the same idea for this
plot which is eliminating the object but
it's reporting the fact that it's being
eliminated
yeah but notice that let's plot does not
report the elimination but you see the
fact that the sixth value is missing
yeah right I mean because this this
could easily be you know if I just say
one three one three well let's see what
happens one three two four missing five
yeah I wouldn't know that from anything
I couldn't tell generally I think we
should design message groups that you
can turn on and off and the question is
what the default behavior done is but
instead of individual messages we should
have message groups to throw I agree and
that relates to my exceptions mechanism
which we need to get back to where where
there's a lot of things which are
messages off by default yeah you don't
really want to manage all of those
messages you know I I'm well aware right
I mean I think that's it but an
alternative way to do it would be to
have an option inside lists plot that
determines the behavior you know we have
this I believe we have a missing
behavior what is it called
do we have a miss yes we have missing
behavior which is now a very random
thing right um I was trying to say
earlier I was muted that right we do
have the concept of message groups we
just haven't maintained it so I know I
know we do what I was thinking is that
and this applies to other things too
because messages are sort of kind of
like a debug.trace like thing and you
typically don't want to run with it on
because everything becomes so noisy but
sometimes you really do you know so but
then we got to make it easy so you kind
of have something along the lines of
themes that there is reasonably sized
chunks that you turn on and off yeah
okay so I mean okay look let's let's
okay so we've got another issue which is
you know in graphics fundamentally we've
got cases where okay that there are
there are two fundamental cases you know
I mean you know this is types of missing
in visualization but it's as I said also
for visualization missing is just one of
the non-anomalous values yeah I
understand I understand so no you mean
anomalous fat too many negations in
there yeah okay so look there types of
missing one there's a place there's a
there's a space where you have to where
you need to put something right so
that's geo value deal cheer engine value
pollens array plants nothing else
Oh throw away okay okay the case too is
you can just leave it out and nobody
would know right that's list plot and
all the others
I guess there's another case where you
can leave it out but it breaks a line a
line surface etc and so right so that's
a case like you're
'we know dateless plot or list line plot
or need yeah let's plot 3d or the thing
what Roger was shown before would those
with that contour thing where it was
where it had a region where the thing
was complex but in that case so wait a
minute so what are the cases so this is
the worst case in terms of messaging
right that case you really you you know
you know you know messages are the most
relevant here because you can't tell by
looking at the picture that there's
anything wrong in this case you can
plainly see the line was broken or
whatever else it would suggest that a
distinction here if you have an a list
of entities for example and one of them
happens to be a missing you could see it
in advance but if you have an entity
class and you try to plot directly the
class and then one happens to be an
missing I think that's important case
because if you don't report it you never
knew you never had the opportunity of
seen yeah well so that's in the in the
you leave it out okay so I mean that's
it so I think what we're concluding here
is that arguably this should generate at
least one message I don't think that
will be bad for that to generate one
message and if you think we have to have
you turning it off of course
people get so excited about having
messages but then they get really
annoyed by the messages so you know I'm
aware but I think one message is not
look a message spew like this is
undesirable this is right I mean what
would be better would be unable to
obtain location information for seven
values that will be much more useful
even more useful would be unable to
locate location information for seven
out of 150 values to I'm saying I think
that will be my favorite kind of message
there without reporting which ones
that's correct if there's only one you
can report it but if there isn't
unable to obtain location information
for seven out of 150 values I mean
that's to me what were useful because
then I can go find out if I then I can
go dig in and say well what were the
locations and then I can see which ones
it couldn't get I mean there's a point I
what I've seen is that to me the fact
that there is a message spew here would
make me want to go back to the code and
see whether I'm not properly listing
things and why is this being done
sequentially to me like multiple
messages from detail that's a detail I
mean are we really serious about that it
seems like a detail to me well this is
not being done sequentially
it's just that I'm reporting the errors
like assume they are hundreds missing
and thousand plotted this the
suppression of the message you get no
idea about the relative ratio so if it
would give one message saying that 412
are missing you would have much more
information I know that's what I'm
suggesting
no no no no no what I'm saying is Carlo
is pushing for a spew of messages I
think that no no no I'm not pushing for
a spew of messages it's only that when I
see a function like Geographics return
multiple messages I always assumed that
I've done something wrong and that I'm
not performing one single point that's
that's a detailed thing which turns out
not to be even the case here but this
seems to me will be a useful single
message for this case and Phyllis plots
you know no coordinates determine for
one out of four points that seems very
useful to me as I accept I'm confused
because I assume that Geographics is not
a hold all or holds first or anything
like that right and so the problem is
not it's isn't the problem is not that
Geographics wasn't able to do something
the problem is that that list of points
that was passed in - no that's a
different thing that's a different thing
because what happened here is
Geographics is dealing with entities
okay
so a better message a message if the
entities have already been resolved this
was just given pure entities it wasn't
given to your position okay okay okay
I'm you know you know it would be seven
out of you know 150 values do not do not
correspond to definite locations or
something I don't know what the right
term is that not quite right but you get
what I'm saying that that's the thing
that that seems to me really useful but
I'm gonna show you these goes back to
Rogers question what happens if it's
test if instead of missing we have none
or undefined or doesn't matter it's the
same thing it's just you're just knowing
this number of points don't have what we
ended up doing and which i think is it's
good to not home in a missing particular
because we'll event something new in a
little while I don't know not
comfortable or whatever missing you know
and and so what we did for this was to
be had to do a you know it's if it's of
this type it's okay if it's not it's not
you know it's a negative definition
everything that's not real is basically
bad yeah II I'm saying yeah yeah
and but that means that if we if we
focus everything in on missing and I'm
not talking about missing I'm talking
about that
no I'm saying okay about missing right
you're not you're you formulated
perfectly well I think this perfect fine
that's what we need to stick with yeah
okay fine
is it the same message for 150 out of
150 no it probably isn't we probably
need to now okay so they're two points I
want to make about this given that we
actually have elaborate visualization
functions we could imagine having a
little footnote here you know 75 missing
values
you know why not did you get what I'm
saying like we do them all from alpha
you know paren 75 missing values I mean
sort of like a legend I don't know if
that's a good idea okay explain if the
plot is not the end of the story it
changes the shape of the result all
right okay okay
so then I think the conclusion is that a
type 2 missing and I say missing in
quotes okay for Rogers benefit oh my god
are smart goods are not so smart if you
put multiple of them together um okay
okay then there are three cases and
let's agree what we're doing with these
I think this is again quite
straightforward compared to some of the
other stuff we have to address the you
can just leave it out then we generate a
message by default but any of these
cases where it's an indicator where
there's an indicator of something being
left out you do not generate a message
by default although you could switch it
on that makes sense
it makes sense this case in this case we
actually have a missing style that's a
case where we have to give a missing
style um
this case could also give a missing
style C style but I mean maybe missing
style but it also needs whatever the
option is to say how to fill in me know
know that that's what missing style is I
mean so in other words know everything
so there's the option of what style it
is but yeah so imagine your list line
plots yep right yeah so you have a gap
and we're gonna bridge the gap
the question is how you bridge the gap
right or perhaps a better example if you
plot X to the minus one-third from minus
one to one right now is that just a
straight line between the points or is
there something else that you know
because there's different strategies for
that it is quite bizarre by the way that
that list plot is a type two and list
line plot is a type three this plot
being type two depends on the data Y
because it depends on whether you're
giving it XY pairs are just a list of
Y's I see I see I see I see um this plot
of XY but not this plot of y1 y2 and and
in alpha for the weather plots we
deliberately make use of the fact that
the missing leads to exclusions in order
to get the excluded line segments to be
excluded so we wouldn't want messages
there where we're deliberately making
use of this pre-existing behavior sorry
I don't understand
you're saying in this case well in this
case there's no reason to give a message
by default because you can plainly see
that there's something missing that's
exactly what I'm saying him right that's
a type three right so in type three we
could have a dotted line joining these
if we do an alpha yep and that's what
I'm saying
eg could style to join with a dotted
line and
that will be a missing style wouldn't it
or am i confused well in the Dardanos
would be missing style okay the shape I
mean in some cases this is very hard for
surfaces this is this is actually hard
because you might have things on the
boundary that are some kind of twisted
polygon or something yeah right yeah so
I don't I don't see that happening very
quickly for surfaces fair enough I mean
services were mostly just leaving a gap
yeah it was very hard to make the gaps
and you're filling in okay so what is
your point at eye about this right so
well how would the missus so I have only
you know which is what is drawn here and
the right half if you we said the nuns
of default missing style what are you
talking about this is in the left half
you mean in the left half insight screen
is flipped left right um okay
that's by the way there is no place in
the world that has their axes by default
label right to left is there no there
isn't that that was just a joke
I sent since my men but my menu bar is
reversed relative to yours right
reversed scaling functions is pretty
calm and oh yeah right and so I put in a
second one where okay okay look it's
high this is exactly an example of a
type 3 where you can plainly see that
there's nothing there right and that's
fine but what's your point I mean
there's nothing to show into oh I see
you're saying in a type 3 like this all
right well what the missing style do I
don't know it I don't think it can do
anything here I don't think it can do
anything I mean the only thing it could
do yeah I don't think it would do any I
see the question would be no that the
case that I think is more interesting is
the case where you usually get the data
case from this by just running a table
instead yes I understand I understand
but but what I'm saying is um or X less
than minus 0.5 okay okay now this case
is more interesting because that case
there are two ends like like for example
even in the weather plot okay if that
missing was at the end what would you do
right in this in this case here in this
simulated weather plot the missing is at
the end what do you do it doesn't even
look it doesn't even reserve space for
it by the way which might be a bug I
tend to think that's a bug okay
okay but but in the case of in this case
here there's a way to join these things
with dotted lines in this case here the
only thing we might do is have it be a
constant value shown with a dotted line
right and that's why I'm saying that you
know there's probably a second option
there of you know you know what your
imputation model is yes it doesn't
bother me that it just stops there right
it that could just mean there you know
that's the last point that the weather
station took and you know check in again
in 15 minutes and maybe they'll have
reported the latest number okay let me
ask this question what about a geo
bubble chart or a bubble chart in
general you don't know how big the
bubbles are
that's kind of a stupid boy well I mean
okay so more what case is that of these
this is you know where the bubble is
okay so let's take a G bubble chart okay
where you know the position of the
bubble where you know the position but
you don't know its size what should you
do
there are another options
well you might want to put an X I mean
potentially it's like you know a missing
Mercker sort of option
yes I agree yes because that's a case
that's it that's a fourth case where you
know the point where something goes but
not how it should be rendered I think
that's your Australia case more or less
it's not quite the Australia case but
not how it should be render because in
the case this is really I'm gonna
reorder these okay
um this is really that's really one one
eh and this this thing that I'm now
describing is one B right well you know
the point but not how it should be
rendered you know the point but but
you're actually representing the okay
here's another case well um here's a
case you know the x value but not the Y
value right so that's one of the list
plots case like but in the case of you
know the x value but not the Y value it
is in fact the case but let's imagine
that in this case here or was it in this
case here you know the the well in that
case the Y value but not the x value in
the case of so let me let me give an
analogy here so if I did these if this
didn't say missing but it said instead
around 0 comma 3 that doesn't work why
doesn't that work oh it did work oh
sorry I should have said 1 comma 3 or
something I don't know very but it's
drawn in the wrong direction which I
filed the other day ok fine good I mean
my point there is um that's really kind
of ok so that would be a way to do you
know that missing could in principle be
I don't think I'm necessarily
recommending this is it a for an
infinite around yeah an infinite around
a dotted line and infinite around
something like that I mean this case
where there's a partial coordinate
okay look bottom line here is there's
stuff to think about in every
visualization type I'm going to do with
missings okay and I think we've got
several tools in our tool chest we've
got you know we first of all we got
message no message we've got an option
you know no option you know an option
like missing style sometimes we're
forced to have some kind of missing
style with it with the definite value
that you'll see sometimes the missing
style by default would just be none and
the thing would just not be there side
say we can improve but that's the place
in the system where I think we've come
too far de stand actually thinking about
missing yeah well fine I was about to
turn to talking about computations with
missing okay so I mean that's that's uh
that's the other case where was it
arithmetic etc etcetera etcetera with
missing okay so when it comes to
statistics there's sort of a model for
each kind of function that one can use
to you know by convention in other ways
but there are models just as the machine
learning based imputation or model-based
but they're sort of appropriate for each
area well let's enumerate some of those
so you're saying in the case where there
is data that is non-poisonous but
missing if I'm making sense mm-hmm um
give me gives
examples of how you might deal with that
okay so typical model for mean might be
just the same model as machine learning
users which is nor in a mostly normal
distribution or multi normal in their
case and that means that you would
effectively replace it with the mean you
know of the others which and but I don't
I don't have a big catalogue of these I
just know that they are different in
each different area we have somebody
from the statistics group here
Ghosh is here yes okay well so can let's
start talking about what these okay so
one one approach is assume the missing
is actually from a distribution is is is
simply not was was simply not measured
and follows the ambient distribution and
that's that's exactly what the machine
learning approaches okay okay so another
case is assume the missing blue the blue
the measuring device to pieces blue blue
the measuring device up in other words
it ie EEG out of range or something yeah
which is okay so this is the machine
learning approach basically machine
learning etc and n statistics approach
uses that to plus traditional statistics
and this is now censored data etc sense
sword etc question mark kind of not
really okay so what are some other cases
I mean what are some other things you
might do with missing so another thing
you might do with missing is most
libraries do is to ignore it okay well
you know something that works automatic
you might the presence of missing
poisons the computation and return an
error ml it's one it's something one
might want to do I mean that that would
be look there are situations in which
you absolutely want that to happen in
other words you say you're trying to do
some very high value computation and you
know you thought you'd measured
everything but whoops you didn't okay
like let me give you an example they'll
give you an example let's say you're
trying to
I mean you're trying to pick the best
person out of ten for something right
and for whatever reason and you're
running this computation you're gonna
select the right person the best you
know the best person but actually you
know some of this you know results
hadn't come in for some of those people
okay you run the computation it says you
know I'm giving a bad example maybe you
make maybe you're trying to do grading
and you're trying to I don't know what
I'm you can play I think grading right
you're you're trying to report
statistics on your how your class did
and oops
you forgot to enter the last five grades
and you know so what you have is
meaningless yes which is means you know
so that's that's okay that's the case
where it poisons so another case is just
drop and a thing that's missing okay now
notice that they just drop anything
that's missing runs into some of the
same issues that we have here because eg
eg if it's a pair if it's you know in a
pair like it's you know five comma
missing do you drop the whole thing what
do you do that you have to then you have
to drop okay so so what just drop
anything that's missing means with more
particularly with look at the elements
going into the computation if one of
them has any part that's needed missing
drop the whole element right that's
basically
what you'd have to do here that correct
Roger that's that's one strategy yeah
well is there a different one for this
case and if well
as I said as a as a matter of procedure
I think most libraries and and other
things they will have a simpler strategy
they say they basically remove elements
that are not of the right form
okay well fine and then you can have an
extended strategy where they used some
named model for how to replace them and
that named model usually comes down to
roughly what you said in the first case
ambient distribution or something else
that is assumed for this kind of
computation
you
right um okay so actually I'm looking at
some comments on the livestream here
assuming the missing is an average is
the same as leaving out for a mean yes
that's correct for a mean specifically
but not for anything else I mean a skew
Nisour whatever else absolutely does not
do that that's a specific property of
the mean now okay so there's there's
another possibility
okay other possibility is um add the
green is mean is a sort of a derived
quantity from a distribution so I
understand so you can do the same analog
for other things you know if you if you
model the distribution you get all those
derived kind of properties okay so this
is another case add a roundness to right
and that case that works for example for
median kind of well explained to me ok
so here's another case so we've got as
we represent missing data we've got a
couple of things we've got we don't yet
have a agio around and probably and
hosea is probably freaking out but even
thinking about that but geo around was
it happened in Poland but I don't know
exactly where that's very weird you know
it happened in this geo circle or
something is that meaningful is that is
that a I mean okay question multivariate
around do we do what how do we think
about multivariate around oh that's why
there is a vector around which has
covariances because i see yeah so is
that an essentially an ellipse is the
vector around defining an ellipsoid yes
yes so in protein functions they ever
its represented the 2d case ass ellipse
right okay so this is okay I understand
so that's what so that's what we're
doing with that so we the the the idea
that it happens within a region is kind
of silly and we're not doing that this
is the case where there is uncertainty
so the question is when things are
missing you know are there okay question
for statistics folk is it am i right
that quotes robust statistics is
supposed to be a case where when stuff
is missing it doesn't make much of a
difference is that sort of the idea no
it's more of outliers so you can have
values that now PowerPoint yeah okay
that's right yes okay it's being
insensitive to outliers yeah right um
okay so are you saying that this case
here of using a roundness to represent
uncertainty is is based on I'm never
going to work median comes down to the
same thing as mean you know in that if
you want a model you can always sort of
give this unbounded uncertainty if you
like and and censoring is doing that you
know they're typically half infinite
intervals the person is gonna die but is
not dead yet right okay
okay but is median around implementable
with if they're missing is there's
missing data it is isn't it I mean in
other words if I take look naively if I
simply take you know this you know
whatever it is and then I say infinity
right and I do median of that um if I do
this okay hold on um I forgot second
why does median refuse to do that
why does median refuse in the case of
infinity that's well-defined isn't it
I'm you think it would be mr. bug yeah I
I think median was more or less defined
in version 5 or 6 okay okay so I claim
without and I think it to work only on
numeric data I think there's a lot of
these descriptive statistics that only
work on numeric data okay well fine so
this is a bug so it should be fixed
there's a problem with that I mean what
is there
roscha I mean Oh looks like about know
they can be improved I don't know if you
know what is me neon if you have
infinity minus infinity it's just kind
of give an error it's not gonna do a
damn thing logically what's the
definition in that case it's undefined
you can't give a value in that case but
in this case you can't give a value
can't you
you're just sorting the things and
you're saying you know now yeah you're
sorting them and you have a few that are
in this in this half line you know off
of tooling off to infinity yeah it's
probably just a subtle bug in the
implementation because infinity and
minus infinity aren't American mmhmm
yeah
and the answer to this question is
exactly the same I mean it should I
would expect it to return mean of minus
infinity comma infinity which is
indeterminate with a message mm-hmm I
would argue it should return whatever
median of empty list returns which is
probably uh unevaluated wait why would
median of minus infinity comma infinity
be the same as median of empty list
because by the median of minus infinity
comma infinity infinity infinity is
different isn't it yeah but that would
be infinity yeah okay but so so what
we're saying here is that
median
could return is it an interval or is it
two values or what is it
no it's if you have if you have n
missings in median
they're just two values right I mean how
many missings you have know am I wrong
no the more missings you have the whiter
deranged because you don't know where
they sort but that still it's still in
it well it's I mean do you have to do a
permutations calculation or is there a
shortcut no I say well I'm sure there's
a shortcut median is basically looking
at the quantile function of the
underlying distribution
right I mean okay but so median is a
case where we could return something
reasonable we could return an error
bounded thing for that it's usually not
so good when you vary the output well
for the consuming function no I I
understand
I agree but we have things like a wrap
you know we have the idea we could have
a median around that would do this even
if it isn't media in itself that does it
even if median itself just punts it says
I don't know what to do but I mean all
of this may be also a bit forced because
it always has some sort of Gaussian
interpretation behind it while these
things fair enough do not need to be
okay but so let's take a look for a
moment and we're gonna run out of time
here but um okay okay so this first case
assume the missing was not measured and
follows the ambient distribution okay by
the way I don't think that is always
what you want um and that's a difference
between X and missing if you have a
machine learning thing where you say
that whenever you see a picture that
looks like this it's X as opposed to
whenever you see a picture like this it
counts as missing so to speak well the
label is missing those are different
things that's kind of obvious that's
obvious never mind that I mean missing
is a special kind of label for machine
learning I mean if that's what look if
the label is missing okay you have some
training data and every picture of a
lion the label is missing I don't know
what you how you want to interpret that
that is ignore that piece of data
because the label is missing or returned
missing if you see a lion did you
understand what I'm saying
I kind of feel that there's more
utilities that can be around you know so
we can make all this descriptive
statistic functions do something
documented behavior possibly options to
control but I kind of feel that there
are other utilities that should be
general data cleaning data handling kind
of utilities but but the fact is there
are things were inside the computation
something has to happen like it has to
do this this some you know you don't
really want ok so look look one thing
you can do is just do you know
synthesize missing data so what we
called it synthesize missing values mmm
and what that's gonna do is it's gonna
take every missing and explicitly
replace it by seven point two eight
point four whatever but that's a
different result from saying you know
it's like a stochastic variable where
you're summing over all possible values
of the stochastic variable distributed
in some particular way am I making sense
it's a different result I mean taking it
and doing something explicit and taking
your data and returning another piece of
data is different from having data where
that where you're assuming that those
values are stochastic according to some
distribution right Roger no I'm I'm not
sure it is it's it is because one of
them you've got seven values there and
they're sitting there as seven explicit
randomly chosen values doesn't mean that
those specifics right right but often
you don't use the you don't often take
one way is to do a random instance like
like your synthesize missing value stars
yes the other thing that you replace
them with with you know like in the case
of mean with their mean you know with
with that property of the distribution
but there's sort of implicitly their
distribution figures in there anyway
well there's the third thing you could
do you could repeal it replace it with a
symbolic distribution but that's that's
not a practical thing to do right
that's that's no I I mean if it's a
Gaussian distribution it might well be a
practical thing to do it so I similar
what around does no around has all kinds
of approximations in run away replace it
with an a round object for example yeah
okay but let's okay we got to wrap this
meeting but but Tim um I was I did want
to talk about the generalization of
delete missing um which is things like
unless missing map on two three four
five missing whatever it is which means
so that would return um
F of four F of five missing F of five in
other words it leaves the missings there
but it doesn't mess with them untangle
everything up is it specific to missing
or what about all the other missing
things
I don't know I don't know I was thinking
it was specific to missing but I don't
know because most of the other things
you know I agree with you something
along these lines that makes sort of
functional programming a little bit more
robust would be you know slightly
because the main point is that that
missing you know you want to do this
unless the data is funky in some way now
I don't know whether missing
okay so there's another case here which
is when you do part extraction and so on
missing type stuff um and there's also
failure yes and dollar failed need that
unless missing for list of all functions
because then it becomes really powerful
to apply F only to a subset of the
values but in a vegetable form
what do you mean brother that means now
that we are mapping over list yeah it's
it might be inefficient we want to apply
F to the non missing values as a list
you in that case yes we we want to apply
F to the list six seven five and then
put it back I don't see how that can be
done in any reasonable fashion yeah it
would be related to subset map but yeah
the positions of the missings or the
compliment of the positions yeah subset
map is a I see all right well the
question mark relation to subset map
this is a whole different discussion um
what happens yeah it's um the livestream
is asking if we say around random real
let's say one random real point
we make a table of ten random missings
I'm ten random arounds and then we say
median of that I think it'll just work
won't it oh why doesn't that work
because because I found just you and we
haven't propagated it there yet no it
may actually be mathematically hard it's
not obvious to me what that would be
mathematically yeah I think that the
problem is for media need to be short
and that suppose that hmm
but there is a there's a deeper model
than sorting for median you know yes I
don't I'm sure you know better but
explain it is there a meaningful value
for this yeah take an ensemble of points
and for each yeah I mean certainly there
is a way Monte Carlo wise to generate
the answer here yeah but I mean
obviously you can tell that nobody has
thought about it yet yeah I can tell
that so we're raising it so um but I
mean the question so is this for the
statistics team or is this what we're
and how many of these things I mean do
we have any idea so mean was
specifically supports around is that
correct not really this worked because
me is going to add the arounds and
divide by the number and because glass
can add rounds then you can do it I see
I see I see so if I say that I'll get
that but if I say sort a percent 51 I'm
gonna be out well you'll get something
because it does canonical order now if
you do numerical sort some of them won't
why did numerical sort work maybe it
should object right well it can because
it went inside and sorted this first
arguments yes I can see but I mean is
that the right thing for it to do what
should it complain that those are of an
unknown sorting order
well I mean they are sortable right as
long as as long as they don't overlap
yes I understand but it soon they
overlap I guess the question is what if
you take two of them and put stick less
in between so take the point eight five
five and the point eight eight and stick
a less between them and what does that
do it does nothing get what you want it
to do well here would be to have a more
powerful function that will say
something like well is this are they are
they compatible with some overlapping
probability or some say that so they
comparing them unless we just compare
the first numbers no that's hopeless we
shouldn't do that you can compare
intervals for example right if there yes
these are not intervals isn't Lisa think
of these intervals they aren't evaluated
to exactly if they overlap two days on
do anything at all right yes yes yes if
you do interval of 0 1 less than
interval of 2 3 but their significance
arithmetic does not our significance
arithmetic gives order yeah I know but
that's because it has to do right so for
things to they're kind of right but I
mean what Sigma would you like it to go
to if these are gaussians to decide that
it couldn't possibly be less than that
well either 3 or 6 depending on whether
you know doing social science or
particle physics
oh god I mean are we serious that we
could do something like that I don't
think that's serious probably not
automatically no but I mean what one
would imagine is something like you know
I mean if this is a stupid name but but
evaluate at 3 Sigma or something and
then you take that use the option
significance level flow in in what well
les doesn't really have a very easy way
to take options but but your your what
would that with that significance level
so what's the probability of something
something this cannot be true well so
les takes the this a parameter called
equal tolerance that specifies the
number of bits that you are considering
I say well that's interesting then then
sequence significance level is not silly
there right it has yes it has some bits
of toriel's yeah I'm probably roll it
the system and terminal function
sorry symbol okay okay but that's not is
that is that a but is that an explicit
is that an explicit option to less or is
it something different well anyway it's
a dollar variable so I think it's like
internal backtick dollar equal to s okay
I think this is actually an interesting
idea this this idea that we could have
some evaluate function that says
evaluate this you know you've got a
collection of things that cannot be
resolved right there you know you could
imagine resolving it to a certain
significance level
I guess because single Ponder's game you
might evaluate every single one
correctly but that's all the story for
what came what Ferrando once that to
losing games may given in game okay
there is no candidate locally you even
if you locally do it always right it's
not cumulative additive and such things
okay all right that's that's a fair
point well it's basically worried about
transitivity of various kinds I think
yes um you do a sample from distribution
a and I'm looking at live stream comment
here it's likely to be less from a
sample distribution B
no this is that what we're asking here
is what's the probability if you if you
convolve the two distributions
what's the overlap probability and so on
all right so this maybe is a knot knot
won't work all right we should wrap this
meeting this is um I think we've got a
few sort of obvious things here are
little baguettes and and this stuff
about the treatment of missing in in
visualization which seems like those are
actionable things immediately and then
we've got we need to loop back again to
talk more about how to handle missing
for these computational purposes and the
and functional programming within less
missing and so on sounds right sounds
reasonable to people mm-hmm all right
thanks everybody thank you two folks on
the livestream talk to y'all soon Hey